monsieur bonsoir tout allait pour le
mieux 1500 exposants plusieurs milliers
de visiteurs en deux jours
les organisateurs de la foire à tout d
ang lee déborder d'enthousiasmé ce week
end
il était en tout cas loin d'imaginer le
drame qui allaitent endeuillé cette
grande fête populaire
hier soir une petite fille de 8 ans
jennifer est morte électrocutée aux
abords d'un manège d'autos tamponneuses
reportage pierre duval ce devait être un
dimanche de fête cette foire à tout des
enduits qui a rassemblé plusieurs
milliers de personnes ce week-end dans
la grande banlieue de rouen
depuis hier soir les indices sont en
deuil la fille jennifer 8 ans est morte
électrocutée par une fille de courant
qui n'a pas encore été localisée
cependant la mort de la petite bonne
femme de 8 ans jennifer est survenue
quelques temps après le violent orage
qui a éclaté hier au dessus des zones où
ce matin les enquêteurs du commissariat
d'evreux et le chef du district edf des
andelys ont procédé à la reconstitution
les conditions de l'accident mortel
on vient de faire ce matin d' essayer de
reconstituer ce qui a pu se passer donc
notamment avec la pluie qui était tombée
à ce moment là on a constaté
effectivement qu'il y avait un courant
de fuite entre le manège et le sol bon
bien anders est un problème
d'installation c'était en dehors de
notre branchement électrique pour le
manage
c'est vers 18 heures que le drame s'est
produit la pluie qui est survenu tout de
suite après le raja provoque une fuite
d'électricité proche d'un enfant à terre
au moment où elle se trouvait au bord de
la piste métallique du manège d'autos
tamponneuses
elle est restée près d'un quart d'heure
au sol tétanisés sous la forte décharge
du courant nous avons immédiatement
pratiqué avec notre médecin capitaine
aux soins de massages cardiaques et 2
insufflations d'oxygène on parle que
d'autres personnes d'autres enfants ont
pu être également électrocuté
apparemment sans gravité mais aux dépens
des paramètres dans lesquelles
on pu se passer justement ce problème
d'après les témoignages l'enfant était
couché à terre et la surface de
réception de cette décharge électrique a
dû est certainement être très importante
en 27 ans de carrière un assureur de
gaillon près des andelys n'avait connu
que deux choix les mêmes conditions
d'une telle tragédie
il s'agissait également d'une petite
fille qui a été électrocuté mais c'est
le seul cas en 27 ans j'insiste bien
d'autant plus que j'ai asus j'assure
pratiquement tous les forains de france
face à romain entre autres puisque vous
êtes dormant on assure 80% tous les
managers scolaires sont assurés chez
nous c'est le seul le seul accident fin
y compris l'hôte de en 27 ans une
autopsie du corps de l'enfant devait
être pratiquée aujourd'hui à l'hôpital
d'evreux sur la demande du parquet de la
ville qui a ouvert une enquête
judiciaire